[Musique]
j'ai passé un quart par semaine j'ai au
moins une heure par par mois à donner
est en effet 7 heures comme ça
positionné n'importe où et compliqué à
valoriser et l'objectif pour nous c'est
vraiment en fait de récupérer toute
cette ressource et de la mettre à
disposition des associations qui en ont
le plus besoin c'est un peu une
plateforme un lieu où les personnes
peuvent donner leur temps qu'on sera
tous capables de prendre notre petit
doigt zine de l'ami au centre de
vaccination parce qu'elle n'a pas de
moyen de locomotion
je reste convaincu que ben voilà donner
un petit coup de main les joue au
scrabble pendant une heure avec pas
forcément une personne seniors mais
peut-être tout simplement quelqu'un qui
a plus de difficultés à avoir du lien
social le plus vite possible
toujours mais honnêtement je pense que
on devrait être prêt d'ici sera un
février à peu près